30. a
warning for women who are undergoing
treatment for breast cancer now you may
think you're doing the right thing by
taking vitamins and supplements but be
sure to tell your doctor everything that
you're doing in tonight's buddy check
details on a new study with an urgent
message
[Music]
a recent study through the yale cancer
center revealed a
whopping 80 percent of breast cancer
survivors
are taking dietary supplements moyer
harrigan is a specialist in oncology
nutrition
and authored the report they fought hard
they got through treatment
and now they're trying to do everything
they can the trouble is
most patients could be getting too much
of a good thing
multiple formulations can lead to
multiple nutrients
a process called nutrient stacking we're
concerned about the fat soluble vitamins
a e e and k because the body
stores those that it doesn't get rid of
what you don't need
it stores those so that's those are the
ones i'm always concerned about herbal
supplements in particular may
interact with tamoxifen and other cancer
fighting medications
lowering their efficacy the herbal
preparations
were interfering with tamoxifen and
aromatase inhibitors there's three of
which there's three
and women who've been treated for breast
cancer who are
estrogen positive will be on
one of those medications for 10 years
so you don't want anything to interfere
with that dose so to be safe
share everything you're taking with your
doctor no detail is too small but if
they're recovering they want to do
everything right they want to take their
vitamins
is it as simple as just bringing the
bottles into the doctor's office or to
the dietician and saying
hey here's what i'm taking is this good
or bad
that is the perfect way to do it okay
bring your bottles in
and better yet eat a healthy diet